hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem missing number
and this is another problem from the
blind 75 list a list of commonly code
questions we've been tracking this is
missing number in the binary category
you'll see why in a moment and the link
to this sheet will be in the description
if you do want to take a look we have
solved most of the problems in this list
so far so let's continue so the thing i
like about this problem is that there's
so many different solutions to this
problem even though it's an easy problem
i think it's a good problem to just
understand a lot of the different
solutions involved with this problem you
can definitely learn a lot so we're
given an array of numbers containing n
distinct numbers in the range 0 to n
even though this range actually has n
plus 1 numbers inside it we're only
choosing n distinct numbers from this
range and we want to return the only
number that's missing from this array so
we want to find the missing number from
this range that that we did not pick
there are many different ways to solve
this problem the follow-up is can we
implement a solution with o of one extra
space and o of n run time complexity
that's going to be the challenge and
actually there's two different ways we
can arrive at such a solution i'll show
you both of them because they're both
pretty interesting okay so in the first
example we're given three distinct
numbers because the length of this is
three so the range that we're looking at
is from zero to three right there's four
different numbers in this range zero one
two and three but we've only chosen
three of them in our input we want to
find the one that's missing so we can
kind of just go through this input right
three okay
the missing number is not three zero the
missing number is not zero one the
missing number is not one so the only
remaining number is two so two is the
missing number that was a pretty easy
way to solve the problem what exactly
did we do right now well you could have
you could think about this list of
numbers as basically a hash set or hash
map or whatever you want and we're
basically iterating through the list of
numbers and then crossing out the ones
that are already uh and contained in the
input list so basically we used o of n
extra memory with a hash set or map and
o of n time complexity because we had to
iterate through the input array so
that's actually the most simple solution
right using hashing to do this problem
but it does take of n extra memory the
follow-up was can we do this in o of one
extra memory there are two different
ways actually that at least i know of
that you can do that so let me show you
both of those right now so one of the
ways that we can solve this problem with
o of one memory is going to be needing
some binary properties and if you've
never really heard of this there's no
way you can kind of figure out this
solution
at least this binary solution it's going
to need the xor operator the exclusive
or operator if you don't know what this
is let me show you let's suppose we had
two numbers let's say we had two and we
want to exclusive or it with three this
is the symbol that you use for exclusive
or so we're taking two and exclusive
oring it with three
so this is a binary operation so we're
going to look at the binary
representation of 2 which is going to be
1 0 we're going to look at the binary
representation of 3 which is going to be
1 1. we're going to exclusive or these
how do you exclusive or you look at each
bit and if only one of them basically if
they're different
if both of the bits are different one it
must be a zero and one must be a one
they could be swapped right it could be
one zero or zero one but they need to be
different and if they are different then
the output is going to be a one if
they're the same in this example they're
both one or if they were both zero that
means they're the same so then in the
output we're going to have a zero so you
can take two numbers like two and three
exclusive or them and we get in this
case an output of one so why is
exclusive oring going to be helpful for
us in this problem well my question to
you is what happens when we take two
numbers that are the same and then try
to exclusive or them so five together
with five so five in binary i think is
one zero one so if we exclusive or these
together what's going to happen well
we're gonna look bit by bit it's gonna
be the same so we're gonna get a zero in
the output again it's gonna be the same
we're gonna get a zero in the output
right if there's 0 0 or 1 1 they're the
same similarly in this case
it's going to be 0 right because of
course when you take two numbers they're
going to have the exact same binary
representation if you exclusive or them
together we're going to get 0 in the
output because they're the exact same
right they're always going to be the
same
so the exclusive or is going to give us
a 0. why is this helpful for us in
solving this problem well basically the
order in which we exclusive or numbers
does not matter for example if i took 5
exclusive or 5 and then exclusive or 3
what's going to be the output of this
well as we just determined 5 exclusive
or with 5 is going to evaluate to zero
right so then the problem is going to be
0 exclusive or with 3. what happens when
you take a number and an exclusive or
with 0 well you just get the original
number why is that the case let's look
let's say we had
1 1 this is our 3 and then 0 is 0 0 0
and if we exclusive or this we're just
going to take all the ones in 3 and put
them in the output right because this is
going to evaluate to 1 this is going to
be 1 and then 0 0's which is going to be
the rest of this thing is also is just
going to evaluate to zero so the output
what we get here as you can see is the
number itself three so when you take
three uh
exclusive or with a zero we get the
three uh and the thing i'm getting at is
this operation it doesn't matter the
order that you do it and if you do five
exclusive or three and then exclusive or
five uh we're still going to get a three
in the output because five exclusive or
with three is going to be something sure
but basically what i'm saying is the
order does not matter right we can say
you know five exclusive or with five
first then these kind of cancel each
other out and then we're left with the
three so why is this going to be helpful
you might be able to figure it out by
now uh because i've kind of explained
most of the logic here so how are we
going to use this simple fact to get the
answer get the missing number from this
range that we're given 0 to 3
we know one of the numbers happens to be
missing how are we going to do that well
we know one of these numbers is missing
from this array right so what are we
going to do we're going to take the
the range 0 1 2 3 exclusive or it with
the input array in this case it's 0 1 3
right we're missing the 2. what's going
to happen when we do this operation this
exclusive or operation well the zeros
are going to match right the zeros are
going to cancel out the ones are going
to cancel out right we're going to get
rid of the ones the threes are going to
cancel out as well and then once
everything is cancelled out the two will
be remaining because it's the only
number that didn't show up twice because
this was the missing number this two was
the missing number so then once the into
this entire exclusive or operation is
done we'll be left with a 2 which is the
answer in this case and we did it with o
of 1 memory because we just had to
really iterate through every number in
this
input array exclusive or them together
and then iterate through every number
between 0 to 3 exclusive or them with
the result of the exclusive or over here
and then once all of those exclusive ors
are done it's basically a linear time
function it's going to be 2 2n because
we're iterating through this array and
iterating through that so it's going to
be o of 2n the time complexity the
memory complexity is going to be of 1
because we didn't need anything extra
and this solution is pretty easy to code
up but there's actually one additional
solution that i think is interesting for
this problem that i'm gonna quickly go
over let me explain how we're gonna
arrive at the next o of one memory
solution and then i'm actually gonna
show you how to do it the simple idea is
gonna be this what if we took the sum of
this range 0 to 3 right basically the
array from 0 1 2 to 3. we took the sum
of this array subtracted from it the sum
of the input array right right if we did
that we took the sum of this subtracted
by the sum of the other array we would
be left with 2 right because 2 is the
missing number 2 is the only number that
shows up here that does not show up here
and then the difference is going to be
2. that's really easy now of course
taking the sum of this array would be o
of n and to compute this it would also
be o of n so the overall time complexity
is going to be 2n and we're not g we're
just going to be maintaining two sums uh
for each of these arrays right we're not
actually going to be conti using any
extra memory so the overall memory
complexity is going to be big o of one
so this is probably the easiest solution
that you can arrive at with just o of
one memory right this is probably the
most intuitive one so this is the one
i'll be coding up but just so you know
you can actually calculate this sum
you actually don't need a loop you can
actually do it in o of one time using
gauss's formula but that's something you
can probably read more about on your own
because it's a little bit extra for this
problem so now let's get into the code
we're going to initially set our result
to zero or are we because what we want
to do like i said is iterate through
this input array nums and then second
iterate through another array basically
the array from zero to the length of
this array nums right
and then just kind of add those together
right we're adding the values from this
array 0 to n and subtracting the values
from the input array but we don't need
two loops to do that because since we're
adding these values
these values are going to be from 0 to
n but we can use the index from this
array nums to actually replace these
values it's more simple than i'm going
to be able to explain so let me actually
just show you what we're going to do
before i actually uh you know try to
explain it so we're going through i in
range length of the input array num so i
is just the index right but we're going
to be using i we're going to say a
result we're going to add to the result
the i value we're going to be adding
this index right that's what we're going
to be doing and we're going to be
subtracting the number from nums right
nums of i we're going to add i but
subtract nums of i from this result why
are we doing that because remember we
want to add every value from here from
this
range it to our result but we want to
subtract every value from nums obviously
we're subtracting every value from nums
but we want to add every value from this
range so with this loop we're going to
be adding every value from 0 to the
length minus 1 because i
because i is only going to go through
every position from 0 to the length
minus 1 uh let me actually correct this
before we get an error uh this is going
to be length minus one right we want to
iterate through every position of nums
so basically what i'm getting at is for
this result we actually have to
initialize not the result to zero but
initialize it to the length of nums
because we want because with this loop
we're going to be adding i uh is it from
zero to length minus one we're going to
be adding that to the result but we also
want to add the final value length of
nums which is basically our n value and
that's pretty much the explanation i
probably over complicated it in this
case it's a little more simple than you
might think
but this is the easiest way to do it
with one loop then we can go ahead and
actually return that result actually i
don't actually need this minus one
because i just remembered that python
the way python works is i will
implicitly it'll it'll stop before it
actually gets to length of this it'll
basically be a length of nums minus one
but by default in python we can go ahead
and run the code and you can see that it
is very efficient so i hope that this
was helpful if it was please like and
subscribe it supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon
thanks for watching